Let me ask you this question, man.
Um who do you believe Yahweh is?
You talking about a who or you talking
about a what? Who? Who is he? Who? Yeah,
out of the persons
is the father Yahweh or is it the son?
>> one of them can hold the divine name.
So, in Exodus for example, it talks
about uh my name is in him.
>> The angel of the Lord?
>> Yep, to the angel of the Lord. So, any
one of the three persons can hold the
title or name of Yahweh as they in in
the So, in the ancient world there was a
concept of the king
sending a messenger that would bear his
name and who would who would actually
speak as if he were the king. In uh the
the in in uh Revelation
uh John sees an angel who comes to him
and begins to speak to him literally
saying like I am the alpha and the omega
and he falls down and starts worshipping
him. That's not an angel. Well, not
Well, well, the thing is is he goes,
"No, no, no." He says, "Get" He's like,
"What are you doing? Get up. I'm a
fellow servant." Yeah, but you said the
angel says that I'm the alpha and omega.
That's That's Jesus speaking.
>> Well, that I might be misquoting it, but
he's My point is is I I might be messing
that part up.
>> But he is what he is doing is the angel
is speaking as if he is Yahweh. No, he's
not. What What gives you the
>> Why is Why did John fall down and Well,
John falls down and worships him and he
says, "Get up."
>> Yeah, so what happens in the context is
John is in awe of the vision that he's
seeing. Mhm. And so, it just says that
at being in all of this, he then falls
down before the angel's feet to worship
the angel. And then the angel picks him
up and says, "Hey, don't do that."
>> Why was he Why would I mean, I can't ask
you these questions, but the reason that
he is asking or that he's falling at his
feet is because the messenger is coming
as if he is God.
>> No. There's nothing in the context that
says anything like that. So, it like I
said, he's showing him the visions in
the heavenly places and the the events
that's going on. John is in such awe of
this that he's he falls down to worship
at the angel's
>> And he begins blaspheming by worshipping
an angel?
>> Yeah, he makes a mistake. He makes a
mistake. That's why the angel said,
"Hey, man."
>> up. Hold on. Back to your question. Mhm.
All three members can bear the title
Yahweh. As the messenger of Yahweh, they
can bear the divine name.
>> Are Are they Yahweh though? Is the
messenger Yahweh? What do you mean by
Yahweh? The one what or the three who?
>> he So, again, when you're saying the
that they can bear the name Yahweh,
you're saying they can bear the name
like it's a title that they can walk
into or carry out their their duties.
>> Yeah. Are they Yahweh though?
Well, are you Are
>> [clears throat]
>> Is Yahweh a who or is Yahweh a what?
>> me a question, man.
>> Well, I'm sorry. I need No, I'm trying
to understand the question. Cuz when you
say Yahweh
>> No, no. No, that's [laughter] He's
asking the question. You got it.
>> but but I don't understand what he's
asking. Okay, look. Cuz would you agree
that Yahweh I mean, Yahweh can refer to
a who or it can refer to a what?
>> when you say a
somebody can go out in the name of
Yahweh, how are you using Yahweh in that
way?
In that way?
>> Yeah.
When someone can go out in the name of
Yahweh?
>> Yes. I would say that they're using it
in the sense that they're going out in
the name of the father. Okay, why?
Because the father is the within within
the godhead relationally, he is the most
high.
I got you. So, to you, the person who is
Yahweh by reference and by like who
Yahweh actually is is the father. The
son isn't really Yahweh. He's just an
agent that can carry the name of Yahweh.
>> In incorrect. No. Yahweh can refer to a
who or it can refer to a what. If it's
talking and and it does refer to a who
is the father and the father's name can
be born by by the other two members as
well.
>> Okay, is is the son referred to as
Yahweh? Is the son referred to as
Yahweh? Yes. Okay.
So, if the son is referred to as Yahweh,
can the son also send someone in the
name of Yahweh?
It's a good question. Thank you. Um
I I don't know if that's a good
question. Um because he bears the divine
authority, yes, he can. He can send
people out in the name of Yahweh. Jesus
does that. He sends people out in the
name of God to do that work.
>> Yahweh. That's why. Well, no.
>> [laughter]
>> No, but you don't Here's the thing.
That's just not to understand the notion
of divine agency in the Bible. The idea
is is that the angel of the Lord is the
angel of the Lord Yahweh. No, he's not.
I'm asking these rhetorically. The angel
of the Lord is not Yahweh. He's the
angel of Yahweh. He's the messenger of
Yahweh, but he's treated as if he's
Yahweh. Okay, if you have a king
>> Okay, can I Can I stop you there?
>> Yeah, go ahead. Okay. So, the the angel
of the Lord, you agree that the angel of
the Lord appeared to Jacob in Genesis
31, right? Yeah.
>> In the dream, remember? And he saw the
stairway. Yeah. Who in the scripture
does it say he saw at the top of the
stairway?
Yahweh. Very good. So, is the And then
in Genesis 35 we get that the angel
comes back to Jacob in another dream,
right? Remember these they're doing the
cattle thing, the spotted thing or
whatever. And he says
"I am the God of Bethel, the one who you
made a vow to." Right? In Genesis 31, it
was Yahweh that he made a vow to. The
angel of the Lord comes to him and says,
"That was me." Right? So, with this
being said is is the angel of the Lord
Yahweh?
The angel of the Lord can bear the name
Yahweh because any
>> Is he? No, no, no. The You have to
remember, when a divine messenger would
go forth for the king in their context
Remember, you guys are reading this
through a modern lens. In the ancient
world, the king would send someone out
who would bear his name and speak as
though they were the king in order to
let people know what was going on and
they would bear the royal name. They
would speak literally as if the king was
there. They were the king.
>> claim to be the king?
Would they claim to be the king?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. If they were
If If they were in the way that they
would speak, they would speak as though
they were the king.
>> No, but I That's different. I know they
can speak as though they were the king.
They come in the name of the king. They
make it clear, "Hey, I'm a
representative of the king." Right? Can
they claim to be the king himself? But
you're you're operating with the word
Yahweh at exclusively as a who. The word
No, no, but the word Yahweh has You said
yourself that the word Yahweh and the
word God is not univocal.
>> That's fine, but it's not an answer to
my question. It can refer No, but that's
the problem is that you're asking a
question without defining the term that
you're asking.
>> No, look. Look. Look. Look.
>> the term Yahweh as a who or or the term
Yahweh as a what.
>> Let me tell you, my my handsome friend
this is what
>> [laughter]
>> This is what just happened. What I did
was is I went by your terminology just
now. Mhm. I asked you, when you say that
Yahweh sends a messenger out and they go
in the name of Yahweh, how are you using
that? And ever since then, I've been
going about how you're operating using
the word Yahweh. Mhm. So, with this
being said, I'm asking can the messenger
or agent of the king claim to be the
king?
He can if he's using the name Yahweh, he
can claim to be
part of that divine council.
>> care about the council. See, you're
doing it again.
>> And I'm not referring to the divine
council. I'm referring to the godhead.
Any member of the godhead, he can say he
can say that I am Yahweh because Yahweh
is a term that can refer to the
>> what I'm asking. Here it is again.
Can the agent of the king who he sends
out "Hey, go to nation Numberia and go
talk to the people or whatever." Can
that agent that the king sent say, "Hey,
y'all. I'm the king and I say boo boo
boo boo boo." Can he claim to be the
king?
>> He can If If you're referring But you're
referring to the name Yahweh in this
case.
>> No, brother. The king. Can he claim to
be the king?
>> I'm talking But this is all in reference
to Yahweh. And Yahweh is a word The
Yahweh No, Yahweh is a word that can
refer He said he's Yahweh, right? Jacob,
the king.
>> No, no, no. He said he's Yahweh.
>> No, the king.
I'm using your example. You're See, this
is what happens.
>> is is that the the king The king's name
in the case of Yahweh can refer In the
case of Yahweh. It can refer It's
referring to Yahweh. The word Yahweh is
a word that you yourself has said can
refer to a what. And if he goes and
says, "Yes, I am that what. Like I am
the I'm in the divine council. I I bear
that name."
>> Yeah. They can do that. Okay. So, let's
pause here for a second on Yahweh. Okay.
The king.
For your example, the king. Mhm. Can the
agent of the king claim to be the king?
Can the agent of the king claim to be
the king? No, he cannot.
>> Thank you.
>> [applause and cheering]
>> BUT HOLD ON. HOLD ON, GUYS. I'm not
done. But before Before we get too
excited here, I just want to make sure
you realize that was an example of part
from Yahweh. When we're talking about
Yahweh No, we're talking about Yahweh
and Yahweh is a word that can be used in
two different senses.
>> Let me Let me show you Look, look,
Jacob. Let me show you again what the
problem is. Just like you did it with
the court with the court example and you
even recognized it doesn't work with the
Trinity, your example here doesn't work
for Yahweh because your example's
showing that people can go as agents of
the king. They can't declare to be the
king themselves. The same way, Yahweh
can send agents, but the agents cannot
claim to be Yahweh or else they're going
to drop dead.
Okay? So, with with with Yahweh So, for
example, you say that Yahweh is the
father.
>> Mhm. You also said that the son is also
identified as Yahweh. Yes. This means
that this either the scripture is
committing blasphemy or Jesus truly is
Yahweh the same way the father is. How
do you reconcile that?
When you say that
Well, no. When How do you reconcile One
more time with the question. So, if you
say that just like how we we just
demonstrated a agent of the king cannot
claim to be the king. You cannot point
to an agent of the king and say, "That's
the king right there." Right? In the
same way, you can't point to any agent
of Yahweh and say, "That's Yahweh." Or
that agent claim to be Yahweh
themselves. Okay? So, if you're
acknowledging You acknowledge that the
father is Yahweh. You also acknowledge
that the son is also identified as
Yahweh. Mhm. Either the Bible is
committing blasphemy and or Jesus is
truly Yahweh in the same way the father
is. How do you reconcile that? It's that
they both are ontologically Yahweh. They
both ontologically are of the same No,
that is not.
>> [laughter]
>> I believe You're You're to say no to
have the same nature to have the same
nature. I believe that they're all
ontologically equal. You have to show
that those three persons actually are
the same being. Would you agree that
>> Not just that they're all ontologically
equal. I believe they're all
ontologically equal. You don't
understand what the Trinity is cuz the
Trinity actually is to say as you said,
it's not just that they share the same
nature, it's that they are the same
being. So you have to establish from the
scriptures that they actually are the
same being. What What's the only thing
we do, Jacob? Read.
>> That's right.
>> [laughter]
>> So,
let's do this really quick. Let's go to
Let's Let's get the Bible.
We're going to get the verse. We're
going to go to Prophet Nehemiah. You got
4 minutes.
I know. Okay.
Okay.
So this is Nehemiah chapter 9 verse 6.
It says,
"You
alone are Yahweh.
You have made the heavens and the earth
and with all their hosts, the earth and
all that is on it, the seas and all that
is in them. You give them uh life and
the heavenly hosts bows down to you."
Who is that?
Who? Yeah. So that's a Yahweh in this
case is a who? That's what I'm asking.
There's only one who that people bow to.
Is it a who?
Is it a who? Mhm. No, Yahweh in this
case is a what cuz it's referring to the
one what. Uh the one what? And what does
this one what consist of?
Three persons.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. So just so you guys know
Apparently apparently God Logic forgot
about that a court is a one what
composed of three separate persons. So
he hasn't actually dealt with it and
he's just putting on a show for you
guys. So
>> [laughter]
>> It's a great show.
Okay. I got I got I got a few more
minutes. He needs to show that the three
persons in the one court, the one what,
actually are the same being. Mhm. That's
the Trinity, you guys. He's just
describing the Godhead model and then
being like, "Oh, I won. That's the
Trinity." No, it's not. The Trinity is
the three persons who are the same
being.
He hasn't shown that. In fact, he hasn't
dealt with all these contradictions in
the scriptures that contradict that
notion that they're the same being.
He just got up and walked away cuz he's
like, he thinks that the Father, Son,
and Holy Spirit are all fully divine.
Ooh.
That's not the Trinity.
If that was the case, by the way, guys,
then Mormons would be Trinitarians cuz
that's WHAT WE BELIEVE. [cheering]
HEY. HEY. IF WE DENY If we tonight
resolve it and now Latter-day Saints are
Trinitarians and now for can be
considered Christians. Thanks, guys.
We're glad to be part of the fam.
You'd have to dump uh the Joseph guy.
[laughter] No, you'd have to No. No, the
issue The issue
Okay. Okay.
>> [applause]
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Um
You know, it's not often that I just let
someone take over my cross like that.
>> [laughter]
>> But when you're working for me, man,
when we're on the same team like this,
you can talk all you want, man.
>> Hey. By the way, you guys think
Catholics are are are Christians and
they don't have to abandon the Pope,
right? Yeah. You're right.
Joseph ain't no Pope.
>> [laughter]
>> No, he didn't kill that many people.
All right. Let's get to Real quick Real
quick though. No, but but in all
honesty, that that is
You You have to understand what the
Trinity is. Okay. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Okay. So um you said that the Father
alone is the Most High. Is that right?
Uh the Father bears the title of the
Most High within the relationship of the
Godhead. Amongst the three, Jesus said
that they are greater than him. So
relationally, the Father is the Most
High, but ontologically, he is equal
with the with They're the same uh fully
divine being. And you Or they're both
fully All three are fully divine beings.
Okay. You You identified You identified
the Father as the Most High in between
the Father, Son, and Spirit.
>> Correct. Is that correct? Okay.
Relationally. Relationally. Okay.
Um when it comes to the Son,
where does he sit?
Relationally? Yeah. He's begotten of the
Father. But where does he sit?
Where's his throne?
On the right hand of the Father. Which
is?
In heaven. Which is Which is sure.
>> [laughter]
>> But But But it's on high. The Hebrew
Hebrews 1 says
>> And he's there with a body, right? Oh,
sorry. Yeah. He says he sits at the
right hand of the of the majesty on
high, right? Is there anybody higher
than that position? No, that's that's
like the whole Godhead model. It's that
the all three of the beings are the Most
High, but relationally amongst those
three beings, you have one
>> them are the Most High, huh? You just
said that the Father
>> I had a court made up of three people
that was the ultimate authority in the
land, that court would be the Most High.
Okay. So when you call you're calling
the Father, Son, and the Spirit a
council, the council of God.
>> I wouldn't call them I'm not I'm not
referring to them as the council of gods
talked about in Psalms. That's not what
I mean. I I mean like
>> before. I know, but they're not the
council of gods in that sense. I'm not
referring to that. They are They are the
council that rules over all things.
Okay. My time is up.